Evet şimdi öncelikle Salonu olan
herkesin bir dakika da gözünü kapatıp şu
sıralar Neyi hayal ediyorsan onu
düşünmesini istiyorum kapatabilirsiniz
ya da vazgeçtim Şimdi burada size
seviyoruz 8 zaten hızla giderken de bu
harcamanıza baktınız kısıtlı her ilk
aklıma gelen her neyse bahsetmek
istiyorum geçmişe kadar müzik çaldım
altın olacağım buraya geldim güzel
kahvaltısı Çok teşekkür ederim aşkım
hissediyorum o yüzden şöyle güzel bir
kahvaltı karşıda ya da güzel mi
[Kahkaha]
bu ve hayaliniz haldız kırılır müzeleri
veya şekilde senin sanırsınız bunları
gerçekleştirerek her korkarsınız sürü
sebep olabilir Şimdi bir yandan da daha
ciddi daha büyük ayarlıyoruz mesela
mesleğiyle alakalı Kendinizi hiç
mühendis ya da daha böyle ciddi olarak
mesela Doktor olabilir Doktor olarak
gördüğünüz bir de bunu yaparken hiç
hayalini bahsettiğiniz d a
bu değer vermesi gerekir Bu işi saatten
sonra siz Sana sorarak para kazanmaya
başlarsınız ve bir şekilde hayatınız ve
siniz ilave devamıdır bir yandanda iki
Yani bir yana akademik bilgisi çok fazla
bilgi veya bazı istekler var mesela var
mı
bir kişi var bende olmasını bekliyorum
ha bastığımızda bu kadar önemli bir
meslek olduğunu bilmiyorum faciye
geçenlerde buldum bir söze kadar birçok
Makine parçası da sonra acılar
yapabiliyoruz en daha da söyle anlatayım
mı
Ne oldu Neden Eyvallah gözleri fazlasını
ulaşacak ama bir şey diyeceksin Sizi çok
seviyoruz hayaliniz gitmek istemiyor
Neden acaba mühendis olmak istemiyorum
ya dedim acaba bakıyor olmak istemiyorum
daha gözümde ve daha kabul gören
pisliklerle düşecek onu söyleyecektim
Siz oluşturuyorsunuz kaybetmek
istemiyorum ama muhtemelen birkaç gün
sonra tekrar olduğu zaman tekrar alması
Birlikler kendi dönecek yani acaba bu
mesleki karar daha gözden geçirirseniz
size ufak böyle laflar yapmaya
başlayabilir ve şey olamaz Sizin
hayaliniz sıkılmaya başlar Kendinizi
yalnız hissedersiniz belki olduğunuzu
kapatırsınız belki ağlarsınız bilmiyorum
ama ben gençler bunların hepsini Yaşadım
Anne Babanın karşısına çıkıp oğlan değil
olması dediği zaman işte bunlar başıma
geldi böyle değişik vakıflarının acaba
vizyon
bu doğru istemiyor herkesin de
oturuyoruz sürekli bastılar ve biraz
kapı salla yapmış O da o zamanlarda ve
En azından sizin de çıkıyor diyor ki o
bir yerde ben size özelden yardım
ediyorum İnşallah Bitirdiğin zaman sen
bu işlerden diye göreceğiz diyorum ve
birden bir ses Geliyorum bu ses benim
hayalin hayalet ve canlı oluşuyor şimdi
[Müzik]
Çünkü babam o
Ne diyorsun ama sizin Yılmaz hazırlık
Yılmaz çalışması yere ama bir fark var
Ve orada başka bir şey yazıyor bu
aşağıda bir şey biraz daha belki sanatla
ilgili daha sosyal resisco tercih sosyal
sosyal Yani birazdan insanlarla beraber
olacağız sahnede oluyor bir şey yapmak
istediğim de tam olarak bilmiyorum ki
bu daha sonra güncel ve geçmiş adama
hangisi var size girdim ve Bensiz olmaz
kapatır vururken de kafamı karışık
anlayabiliriz bu Sağdaki bilmezmiş
fotoğrafını gösterecektim ama bizden
ödemeyi geldi oluyorum ve üniversiteye
gidiyorum İşletme bölümünde işleri
bölümünde zaten kafamda tek olan şey var
O da Şu Dünyada Milyonlarca işletme var
Muhtemelen değişiklik okursak bu
videonun kadar biterse gibi bir şekilde
olabilirmiş Biraz kestireceğim karar ver
Aslında dayanamadım almadım çünkü o da
beraber arkadaşlar yapma kişi okumaya
getirir ve bu dönemin sonunda giden bile
nasıl kanıtlarım kazandım nasıl ailemden
biraz daha koparım her Boğazlıyan
indiriyoruz incele
ver Ver bakayım gelirken para
kazanmasını çalışmaya başladım benim
için her zaman kendi falan kazandım çok
önemli olduğunu Bu bir anlamda belki
özgürlüğü ifade ediyordu Bir yandan
alemde olan dağılmaz vardı ama neden
bilmiyorum ama ben kendim kazanması
çöker olduğunu her zaman bu şekilde
bildiğiniz gerektiğini düşünüyorum
Diyardan Tabii ki benim döneme kadar
aldığınızdan destek almanızı hiçbir
yakıcılar alıyorsunuz olmasın abim size
hayatı karşısı hazırlıyorlar Onu da
söyle şey sadece böyle daha sonra o
ve sırt çantalı otellerde kalmalı adlar
yüzme kovaladığı bir arkası Ya sen 34
arkadaşım vardı ve bir arkadaşımla
geçeceğiz iki doğru şöyle bir gece günü
var oraya gideceğim ben tabii tabii ki
geliyorum gittik önleme şişlik okuduk
nasıl gideceğimiz için nasıl geçeceğiz
bundan sonra kestirebiliriz derken belli
[Müzik]
İçerisi daha yani
Ve o an karar verdim ben bir olacaktı ve
daha sonra her güzel şeyin sonu
olabilirdi farklı birlikte ülkemize geri
döndüm ve babamın karşılaşır baba dedim
DJ olacağım burada karar İşte o dönemde
hayatında yepyeni bir sayfa açıldı
yepyeni bir olayla karşılaştım onun
resmini öyle yaptılar ben o güne kadar
önemli bu kadar yanlış olduğunu
bilmiyorum aslı öyle geldi hayatımızın
her alanında karşımıza çıkıyor Al bunu
anlamakta bitiren Ama aklıma gelen
görmekten bahsedeceğim Esra sizi Eğer
kendi kendimize kazanmaya başladığı
dönemde Oraya giderseniz Muhtemelen ilk
şöyle kendinize ya bir iğne yaptığı
olabilirsiniz
Ya aslında Doktor tanıdığınız varsa
bunun böyle olmadığını anlayabilirsiniz
çok basit Çünkü doktoru üzere uzun
süreli eğitim olursunuz Daha sonra
üzemezsiniz kalmadı diyorum ben sözümüz
oluyorsunuz bilmesi göremiyorsun şu
sürekli hastalığı yapıyoruz Eşinize
sevgilinize sağlayabiliyorsunuz de
doktor olarak Aslında ilgilenmekten
öksürüyor sonucunda Doktorlar Sizler
buyuz bizi bu özveri karşı bir para
alıyorlar ve siz Aslı böyle yerleşimin
olduğu için ona baktım arabası mı yok
yapar oldu değil yaşı görmüyorsunuz bir
düşün bunu Macide ile kendine örnek
vermek istiyorum ben DJ ve
bu üstüne bakıyor Adam siyah çökmüş
beyaz baskısı var mı Gözü dövmeler var
kesin diyeceğim diye bir bölüm çıkıyor
ama benim düşüncelerim sadece bir
sonraki pişirebiliriz kimdir ne yapar
bir kalbim var Ayrıca şansı varmış ve
varmıyor ve ben bugün işte orada
karşılaştım ve eğer bunu Yani bir
şekilde benim iyi olmamışım farklı
farklı sebepler göstererek karşılaştılar
oradan şekilde kafama bir olmayı
tanıştım ve o ara aklıma Bazı Düşünceler
gelmiş gibi bunu da şimdi bu konuşma
hazırlarken şöyle bir cümleyle özetlemek
istiyorum kayboldu
O öyle yazdı Ne yazdı diye olur
yararlıdır ancak şımarmaya çok az fikir
verirler yani yargılar bazı şeyleri Siz
anlamanız açısından iki verirler Ancak
bu şekilde da
Sen bana görüldü verse bir şeyler olsa
da babam hani bir şey bırak dedim ve bu
Yıldırım karşılık buradan önce hürriyete
İşte en iyilerini aldım Daha sonra dünya
çapında gelecek vadeden dediğin şeyden
bir seçildi vererek tüm dünyada
yetişiyorlar ve bizi bir dünyanın
hazırlıyorlar 15-20 TL gitti farklı
yerlerde bileceğiz yaptın inanılmaz
insanlarla tanıştık vazgeçişi de Daha
sonrasında dünyanın o dönemki en iyi
bildiği halde doğru az geldi Hatta o
[Müzik]
Ama bunlar oldu Daha sonra babam yavaş
yavaş benim Artık diyecek olmak
istediğimiz kafaya koydum bu o da anladı
Hadi yavaş yavaş Işık yapıyordu ama
bizim mahalledeki senin bildiğimiz her
yaşamak istiyorum sen boşu nasıl
yapıyorsun Neler yapıyorsun görmek
istiyorum yani hayatım ki söylüyor bu
işte o gün çok yoğun gibi önce
topraklarımız daha sonra sorunları var
Sonra mesajlar sosyal medya paylaşımları
inanılmaz oğlum yine sonra farkında ki
oldu İnşallah parfüm Tamam ve ben seni
yapmışım bu kadar önemli bu kadar gibi
bir şey olur bilmiyorum Gerçekten mi
bu yanlış yapabileceğim konusunda çok
mutluyum o an dediğim gibi çok
rahatladım Artık benim de kendime ait
olan düzgün yerine geldi ve şimdi konu
konuşmalıyım başlayabilirim Siz de
hiçbir şey hayal edin diye Şimdi
tekrardan bir şey herhalde ama bu işin
hayal ederken daha önce yalnız olsun
mesleğinizle ilgili geleceğinizle ilgili
ve bu şimdi uyuyor Şimdi uyuyor bu hayat
sizin hayalinizde bir başkasının
hayalini bulursunuz demek istediğim şeyi
asla su değil aldığım babamızın ağzı
size vermek için de döner senin gibi
sevdiğiniz insanlarla kardeşi zor çok
yani Ama bir şey sonra ayağınızı Siz
geçeceksiniz Sizde iyi seçerseniz olacak
Bunu kesinlikle atmamız lazım ve
bu kendinize güvenmeniz lazım ne
yaparsanız yapın bu işi en iyi şekilde
yapmaya çalışacaksınız bir işi sevmeden
yapmak hayatımızın Aslında at boşa gider
bir zamandır değer severmiş yaparsan
olur başladı biz Ama dediğim gibi
sevgide bakmanız hiç her zaman ve
konuşma Bence o
abone ol